foreign
Google's Enterprise data warehouse
bigquery helps you analyze large-scale
data and gain valuable insights from
your data with ease however as your
usage evolves and expands you may be
looking for opportunities to further
optimize the performance of your
workloads this is where bigquery
reservation comes to your rescue
bigquery reservation make it easier and
helps you manage your workloads
efficiently by allowing you to tune how
bigquery allocates your compute
resources in this video you will learn
how to use bigquery reservation within
the flat rate pricing model to share
committed capacity across the workloads
and projects to optimize your workload
efficiency to begin let's take a quick
look at some of the concepts relevant to
bigquery reservations and workload
management slots are basically virtual
CPUs or workers that are used by
bigquery to execute your jobs commitment
is the amount of bigquery compute
capacity or a number of slots purchased
for a particular duration of time the
most you purchase the more concurrent
queries you can run reservations is a
mechanism that allows you to split the
slots purchased into separate buckets
and allocate them to individual projects
or workloads
assignments are used to assign one or
more projects or folders to a
reservation based on your needs keep in
mind if assignments are not created
slots will be shared automatically
across the entire organization even with
reservations and assignments in place
bigquery continues to optimize resource
utilization with its idle slot feature
this feature enables bigquery jobs in a
reservation to use any idle slots from
other reservations however it is
important to note that idle slots are
preemptable that is if the original
assigned reservation needs the capacity
the idle slots will be returned back
immediately and the job which were
consuming those idle slots simply go
back to using the resources from their
own reservation here are a few details
to keep in mind when designing how you
use bigquery reservations reservations
cannot be shared with other
organizations commitments purchased in
one project can be shared with other
projects but not moved to a different
project bigquery jobs running in one
reservation will use idle slots from
other reservations by default however if
you want to enforce a reservation to use
only the idle slots assigned to it then
you can disable idle slot sharing by
setting ignore idle slot flag to true
alright let's dive into an example of
how reservations can help you manage
your workloads let's say you have
purchased a 3000 slot commitment you can
then allocate these slots to separate
reservations aligned to your various
workload needs for example create one
reservation with two thousand slots and
assign them to all projects for your
data science workload a second
reservation with 500 slots for your ELD
workload and a final reservation with
500 slots for your bi workloads
now projects within each workload can
use the slots assigned for the specific
work
this structure helps you to prioritize
slot reservation by reserving most lots
for critical workloads while reserving
fewer slots for non-critical workloads
let's head into the bigquery console and
see this process in action
in the capacity management tab I'll
purchase a commitment of 3000 slots with
flex commitment and preferred location
as United States
click next and confirm the purchase
you can now verify your purchase under
slot commitments great now I'll create a
reservation for data science project
with 2000 slots you can check the
unallocated slots under the capacity
summary create an assignment for the
data science project
next create another reservation and
assign 500 slots each for elt and bi
workloads
finally I'll assign the projects to elt
and bi reservation
and that's it we have successfully split
up three thousand slots into three
separate reservations
now let's see how these slots in the
reservation can be shared with the help
of idle slot feature
assume a scenario where a bigquery chop
a is initiated at time T within the data
science project initially the job is
utilizing the full 3000 slots reserved
since all these slots were idle now what
happens if a new job kicks in
let's say a second bigquery job B is
initiated at time t plus 5 within the
elt project and the job requires 300
slots and at t plus 10 a third bigquery
job C is initiated within the bi project
and requires 200 slots bigquery
automatically manages the capacity each
time by pulling back the slots reserved
for elt and bi projects respectively and
reallocating the slots to jobs B and C
the individual units of work in job a
are gracefully paused and are resumed as
the slots become free note that this
reservation Arrangement ensures that at
a given point no one job consumes all
the available slots and guarantees that
the slots are provided as per the demand
to learn more about bigquery reservation
and how to manage workloads more
efficiently refer to the below
documentation thank you for watching
foreign
[Music]